hello my name is Caleb Dendy and today
we're gonna be going over a game between
Magnus Carlsen and Vishy Anand fishy Don
of course a legendary world champion
from the 2000s going into the 2010s and
he might have retained his title if not
for Magnus Carlsen coming onto the scene
you could say that's uh you know Vishy
Anand was looking to be world champion
for a long time but no one told him life
was gonna be this way on game review so
in this game this she started with night
with d4 Knight of six c4 e6 Knight c3
Bishop b4 and we have the nimzo-indian
defense this you chose actually one of
my favorite responses to the nihms oh
the f3 nimzo-indian Magnus did not play
one of the most respected lines actually
these days C 5 has been giving black
good chances against the f3 Enzo I
really like this line for black Magnus
chose d5 instead there are other options
as well of course white played a through
a3 rather be take C everybody takes c3 B
takes c3 and now c5 we see C takes d5
from white pretty much the only main
response and now what strong players
normally do is play Knight takes d5 and
if I can equalize pretty easily in this
line instead though we see II takes d5 a
much less common way of playing at the
top level white plays III in Magnus
Carlson's idea here was this move c4 and
the idea of this move is that
this Bishop is always gonna be stuck in
second gear it can't get out to this d3
Square where it's gonna be happiest
you know attacking the Kings side
controlling this Queen side as well d3
you know would have been the best place
for this Bishop but for this bishop it
just it hasn't been it's de hasn't been
its weak hasn't been it's month or or
even as year it's just stuck here on f1
after c4 c4 of course though not without
its downsides when you push this pawn
this far one of course you're spending
time to do that so you're losing a
little bit of time that could be used to
develop your pieces and castle your King
you're also losing
on the center so you're no longer
attacking this d4 pawn with your C pawn
and what that means is white is a little
bit more free to get this key for push
and without without worrying about his
deep on and so we'll see the game kind
of revolve around this imbalance here
white plays ninety two black develops
with knight c6 and now white plays a
very interesting move G for this is
actually the main way of playing against
this c4 break by playing the move c4 you
know like I said black is relieving a
lot of pressure on the center so white
is more free to kind of just go crazy on
the Kings side he's gonna have this
central advantage and he's gonna use it
to attack the Kings side especially with
this Jeep on a side note about the Jeep
on one reason white moves it immediately
is because this bishop is now going to
come to the g2 square white plays earth
sorry black plays castles in this case
white brings this Bishop out to g2 and
now we see Knight a5 from black uh other
than another bonus to having this pawn
on c4 is its control over the B 3 square
black is gonna bring this Knight into B
3 and trade off this annoying Bishop
that white has white simply castles
black plays Knight b3 and now this she
plays the move rook a 2 and this is a
perfectly fine move it's a well
respected move but honestly I think I
prefer the second most common move here
rook b1 and the reason for that is
something we'll see in the game
continuation actually so white plays
rook a to and now in the game Magnus
simply continues with b5 and I prefer
the rook being on B one against b5
because we simply have this nice
pressure against the beep on in the game
Vichy actually plays this move Knight g3
and this is another move I kind of take
issue with I much would have preferred
to see rook b1 let's say we continue
with b5 which is a most common way of
playing now white can play E for
actually immediately and the idea is
going to be after D takes E and F takes
E it's true that black is able to go up
upon by taking on g4 but this Jeep on
simply isn't going to be
relevant to the game white doesn't care
so much about the Jeep on he cares about
this crushing central majority that he
has and that's what he's going to use to
try to prove an advantage here and now
rather than bring this night to g3
actually bring it up to f4 where it's a
little bit more active creates a few
more threats against the black position
notably keeps an eye on this d5 square
allowing white to push 'if I've a little
bit more freely instead though you know
Vichy plays rook a to which is fine it's
fun but I don't think it's the most you
know most pressing way to play this
opening with white so we see b5 because
she brings the knight to g3 and after a
5 vichy first plays g5 kicking this
knight back to e8 and only then
continues with E for what black now
takes this opportunity to take the
bishop off the board before it escapes
to the f4 or e3 squares white captures
with Queen take c1 and now black has a
problem to solve he wants to play b4 of
course he can't immediately due to this
pin in this case actually Bishop e7 it's
kind of the standard way of defending
the rook to play b4 but in this case the
bishops happy on c8 it guards the f5
square and it doesn't really want to
move off this diagonal so for that
reason Blackwell actually plays rook a6
here kind of a weird-looking move but it
defends the rook and the rook helps
defend the Kings side and it advances
his plan of playing B for white
continued with e5 a very natural way of
playing simply increasing his central
advantage and getting ready to push this
F pawn into Magnus's face black plays
Knight c7 supporting these pawns
supporting the e6 square as well and
once again preparing this move b4 we see
f4 from white very natural just
continuing with the plan and black
finally breaks through this move b4 and
now white actually captured this pawn on
b4 opening up the a file but after doing
some analysis on this game I think a
better move for white is actually to
keep the a file closed keep things
locked down a bit because the second
rook for white can actually be useful in
this attack
just for an example line here you can
imagine white or black plays b3 we can
see it swing this work over to f2 and
after g6 f6 now there's going to be
threats to this King and I think white
might just be doing a little bit better
than in the game continuation because
these two rooks do a better job of
stopping the b-pawn then one roof does
it kind of gives white an extra piece to
attack with while still keeping an eye
on the b-pawn not letting it promote in
the game though white does capture on b4
black captures and then we do see this
one set of rooks come off the board and
I really think this is a favorable trade
for black in this case the game
continued with f5 black plays b3 and now
white continues with Queen f4 so we kind
of get an interesting dynamic here where
black is pinning all of his hopes on
this beep on one little beep on going to
try to to Queen in the meantime
white is of course looking for blood
he's trying to checkmate black with
these major pieces black brings this
knight back to c7 and we'll see the idea
momentarily f6 is responded to with g6
keeping things closed at all costs and
now the reason the night drop back to c7
is pretty clear it's going to come to e8
to stop checkmate on the g7 square Queen
h4 from white anyways we see 98 Queen
age 6 of course keeping this pressure up
and now b2 and this is a very very
interesting position here vichy went for
the move rook F for the idea being
checkmate pretty natural there's one
obvious downside to this move and that
is black gets to Queen and unfortunately
for Vichy so far this game was very well
played by both sides the balance was
kind of being maintained with both sides
going for their attack but on this move
Vichy let it slip he had to play the
move Bishop f1 the idea being there's no
good way for this Queen to get back to
defend the King's side you have to play
Queen d1 and after a cage for you have
to give up this Queen for the night and
go in
for a position like this which it turns
out the way it works out it's gonna be
about equal in this endgame with black
probably worming his way into the
position to give a perpetual on this
white King in the game though this she
blocked with the wrong piece he chose
the Knights and now of course after
Queenie one this queen is always gonna
be there for Magnus you could say it'll
always be there for you Magnus guarding
this h4 Square after a cage for simply
Queen takes h4 would be played and black
is just gonna be up a crushing amount of
material one extra rook to his name and
he can now activate his queen and in
fact in the game after Queenie one vichy
simply resigned and that is one of the
key games that led Magnus Carlsen to win
his first World Championship match thank
you very much for joining me on this
episode of my name is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time